your life
thank you good evening and welcome to
this meeting of performance governance
and audits committee on Thursday the
27th of July 2023. my name is councilor
Vanessa Bell and I'm the chairperson of
this committee so with just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present you are giving your consent to
being recorded during each item please
put your hand up to indicate if you wish
to speak I will then invite you at the
appropriate time could I ask members to
avoid approaching the top table in case
you get all caught up in leads and wires
and various things or interfere with the
live stream
and please note that the YouTube live
stream sound recording is dependent on
the correct use of the microphones
so therefore can I ask that when invited
to speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the gender
papers and please keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
thank you
apologies for absence I believe we have
cancerous stamp cancer still councilor
Bassinger and councilor Pratt is that
right look
we have cancer found in attendance
substitution for cancer pract councilor
Hayward substitution for cancer stamp
and cancer lag and substitution for
cancer spills super thank you very much
for that look
brilliant so um minutes of the last
meeting it's recommended that the
minutes
counselors I'm so sorry
um as far as councilor Bassinger is
concerned there was no one in our group
that was able to substitute for him okay
thank you no he did but he was seeking
one but wasn't able to thank you thank
you for clarifying that Chancellor sure
to see that's brilliant thank you
minutes of the last meeting it's
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 15th of June which
I've found on pages 5 to 12 are approved
as a true and accurate record I so moved
do I have a second
thank you
um can we agree those minutes by by a
cent members
agreed super thank you very much let's
stay with me
belongings out of the way
okay
Matt is rising it's recommended that the
matters are rising from the minutes so
that the meeting held on the 15th of
June 2023 found on pages 13 to 14 are
noted I so moved do I have a secondary
thank you
[Music]
pleasure of Interest item five
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registral interests and non-registerable
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regards to
paragraph 9 and appendix B of the code
of conduct for members
members any disclosable interests
no super thank you
thank you I must remind members that
should any interests arise throughout
the meeting
um you would need to let us know so
I believe item six that we don't have
any public participation this evening
I've not been advised of any
so we can move on to gender item seven
external audit report which you can find
on pages 15 to 18 and I'm going to hand
over to Ms Lucas so present that thank
you thank you chair
um so um I'd just like to draw a members
attention to the fact that we've got um
Paul hewittson from Deloitte Suzy our
associate partner who um delivers our
audits on on the line so um yeah I might
hand over to him in a minute if he's got
anything else he wishes to add
um
so I'd just like to draw men's attention
to the fact that there was a previous
report
um it's very similar in nature to this
that came to the committee in January
and a lot of the information provided
within the report
um uh is a kind of repetition of some of
that information because in some
respects um the the situation hasn't
moved on massively so I haven't kind of
sought to
um yeah replicate everything that was in
that previous report but I'm obviously
aware there are new new members who went
on this committee at that at that point
in time
um but yeah if you if you want some
further detail you can refer back to
that previous report as well
um so in summary I think the sort of
position in the report should be
reasonably self-explanatory so I'm not
going to sort of take you through it all
in in detail but the council has
published its unaudited accounts um for
the past three years um which are 2021
21 22 and 22 23 by the deadline however
the audits for all three of those
financial years currently are ongoing
although we are
um things cost very
um close to closing of the 2021 accounts
now
um so I think that one we're hoping to
have um signed off over the summer
um with the intention that we would
commence on the 21-22 audit in in the
Early Autumn in September
um so the reason for that are set out in
the reports and there's various um
contributing factors to to the delay in
the audits
um many of which on um sort of felt
nationally so we're definitely not alone
in this situation and most councils
um face face delays in their audit due
to the capacity of the audit market and
and another of other contributory
fractures that are set out in the report
um
so there is also
um an impact on audit fees and we are
expecting those to increase
significantly in the in the coming years
um I've set out in the report what we
expect the audit fees to be for for the
um
current audits that we're undergoing but
um the
um
psaa who set the audit fees for the
future years have indicated that there's
likely to be
um a sort of national increase of around
150 in audit fees
um from next year onwards as well so
that that will also cause further
pressures on our budgets
um just to make members aware that from
23 24 onwards
um the council has new Auditors that
will be KPMG so
um this Current financial
um
sorry 2223 will be the last
um audit that is carried out by by
deloitte's
um I was also just quickly going to add
a sort of PostScript to the report
because since the report was published
um
see like the the Department of Housing
and local government have sent a letter
to council setting out that they're
working with organizations across the
local audit system to develop proposals
to address the significant backlog of
audits in England and they're looking to
provide a sustainable solution to
um the the issues that um I mentioned
that all councils are facing in terms of
the timeliness of those audits
um so they're planning to consult on
that over the Autumn um and they're
hoping to come up with some proposals to
implement in time for December so
obviously that won't impact on the
immediate workload that we've got in
terms of
um the 20 21 and 2122 audits
um and we will have to wait the outcome
of that consultation to see if there is
any
um sort of national solution to clearing
some of this audit backlog so that we
can move forward into the future years
um so I think that's probably all I was
going to say and I don't know if Paul
did you want to add anything to that
I don't know
that was fairly comprehensive
you know anchor your points
and we have a plan to move on to the
2122 audit in very quick success to see
if we did that finish and we are ironing
out the last few items on the 2021 audit
currently
super thank you very much for that so
the recommendation which you can find on
page 15 is that members consider the
report so do I I so move do I have a
seconder thank you cancer Thompson
um I will now invite members to make any
comments on the report
members Council again
thank you chair it's a couple of um
points and a couple of questions really
um one is that I understand a meeting
took place with Mr Leslie with councilor
stamps and Council of flemen and
Deloitte it was back in January and they
said it would be completed by March the
audience so is there more of an
explanation that the council can have
about the unexpected challenges which I
know you've highlighted a lot you know
with the the markets and the failures of
carillion and Patisserie Valerie etc etc
um but really what are the unexpected
challenges that have contributed to this
delay after the conversations that were
held on the first part of this year
so that's a question and the second one
is a point on page 16. 4.3
just bear with me a second it talks
about
there will be some several material
adjustments that be made what what are
they
um yeah are you happy to answer those
I've got a couple more but I just don't
want to bombard you with loads well I'll
start with um those if you're happy
tonight yeah thank you to defer to um
Paul sorry I can't see yourself
I'll I'll pick those up and then Paul
again might want to add something
um to the comments um
yeah so obviously I only started
relatively recently so I can't comment
necessarily on conversations I've had
prior to my arrival but I I
um obviously understand that the best
intentions in January were to complete
the audit um as quickly as possible at
that point
um
I understand that there have been sort
of a number of
um uh sort of issues and adjustments
that have been made over the course of
the last six months in terms of that set
of accounts and I think it has been an
iterative process in terms of
um the council
um you know working on some of those
items and then the audit feedback and I
think it's just taken longer than
originally anticipated at that point
um I don't know if Paul you want to say
anything specifically around that that
point because obviously I don't have the
full history
yeah I mean
you sort of did a while that you know we
did have an aspiration to get it done in
March uh but some of the information
that we're waiting for has proved very
difficult to obtain particularly around
the gross internal areas of some of your
assets which we need to complete
evaluations work but also
as your Android phone said and there is
an interesting process to it so once we
got into we've got to try to close down
pieces of the room we discovered that
there were further problems particularly
with the comparative period
um which is required the finance team to
do some extensive digging to identify
why could compare the period did the
peer work and then to prepare some
corrections which we then need to take
through in consultation so the amount of
work for me to do has expanded right and
there's been difficulty obtaining some
of the information which has been lost
in the best of time within the council
um or a particularly on asset valuations
and where assets are and what assets are
and how valuations tie back to the
original assets so it isn't that we've
just sat in our hands and not done
anything we've been working the problems
steadily since from about 18 months now
um but we are in the final lap we've got
most of them Equity there is one or two
last bits that we need
I understand that's being chased down
currently
and will continue work constructed with
a finance team to try and get this one
finalized as quickly as possible
um
yeah if you want to come back to the
extent the adjustment adjustability to
talk about as well um well I was just
going to refer members to the previous
report that I mentioned which um was
taken in January and at paragraph 4.3 of
that it does set out um like well all
the adjustments at that point that were
that were highlighted
um I can just run members sort of
through the the headlines of that but um
and I can sort of send around that link
after the meeting so you can have
another look if you like
um but the the major one was
um around the covid grants so
um obviously that's um a kind of
exceptional item that the council hasn't
had to deal with before
um in terms of the grants that were paid
out to um businesses and that was 28
million pounds so obviously that was a
very material amount
um and the way the council had treated
that originally was that that
expenditure was coming through our own
income and expenditure statement
um but because the council essentially
is just acting as an agent to pass those
monies on to
um from government and they shouldn't
have actually been included in the
figures so they had to be reversed out
and obviously that was a material
adjustment that had to be made to the to
the accounts
um there's a couple of other ones which
are reasonably material in nature
um so depreciation and there was a kind
of historic issue
um whereby some revaluations were
understated and they had to be corrected
going back a number of years
um and that had a material impacts again
on some of the accounts so
um that was around 1.9 million so that
again that had to be adjusted in the
accounts
um and that the the third one I'll just
draw attention to is a pension valuation
um and that wasn't necessarily an issue
with the council
um but the the draft valuation Figures
were used in the accounts and
um
once we had the final evaluation figures
and there was a sort of material
adjustment that was required
um and and that didn't have an impact on
our bottom line but it did need to be
sort of corrected within the accounts
once we had those final numbers
um there are a few others but I won't
take you through them because they are
they are available yeah but just to give
you an idea of the sort of some of the
nature of the things um is is there
anything else you wanted to add on that
Paul thank you both
no you probably hit all the ones that I
would have mentioned the only ones I add
are the more recent ones with the
restave and the prior CIS and cash flow
statement to correct the the emissions
from the prior numbers
um
other than that you hit you hit the
highlights does that answer your
question Council again yeah mostly
although it triggers more questions and
answers unfortunately but I'm not going
to do that now
um I ask you to speak up we're having a
little difficulty with your sound
apparently so if I could ask you to to
[Music]
as I said there's more I think there's
more questions than that have come out
of this as well
um
um Mr is it Mr hewittson and you said in
your statement that we're very close how
close
for signing off 2021
and unless you want to do that Miss
Lucas um sorry can you I'm not sure if
you um Paul can hear you very well um
is that one better
um so um cancer login was asking about
how we said we're very close yeah two
mics on councilwagon could you turn your
mic off while um Miss Lucas answers your
question please thank you apologies yeah
um so yeah I'm sorry Council lager was
asking um how close we are to closing
off 2021
um yeah so I think as as you said we we
we're almost there aren't you I think um
we've kind of adjusted that everything
that we know know about I think you've
just come back with like one or two
um minor things that we still have to
chase up as you say but I'm reasonably
confident that we we will get that um
done in August
um so that would be my view thank you
thank you very much
thank you any any more questions members
no okay so um
are we happy to um
yeah I'll be considered happy to agree
that by scent members
of this consider it considered
um moving on then to item eight which is
the internal audit report and that can
be found on pages 19 to 20.
um and we've also got annual report
we've got Little Numbers annual report
an annual statement of assurance
progress report follow-up of
recommendations report
budget and Performance Management to
final report as well in this so I'm
going to hand over to Mr Rubens from BDO
please
thank you and good evening everyone
um so I'm Greg rubins I've um
effectively acted as your head of
internal audit and have done for 22.23
um I'm going to be handing over to a
colleague for next year Aaron winter who
is next to me so he'll be presenting
some of these papers tonight
um we'll take each paper in turn if
that's okay so the first one is 8A which
starts on page 21 of your pack it's our
annual report so this is a summary of
the work we've done in the years so all
of these reports are either later on in
the agenda or have been presented to
previous meetings
um but we do give an overall opinion on
your controls and governance for the
year and we've given moderate Assurance
so that's the same level as we've given
um certainly for the last few years it's
our second highest level of assurance
it's basically means reasonable
Assurance
um and I think that reflects uh the the
reports in the years so the vast
majority have been either substantial
Assurance or moderate Assurance on the
individual reports a lot of positives
there you know good Assurance on the
Main Financial systems and on your
performance reporting the one report
that got um part limited Assurance is
the one on safeguarding which has been
discussed at previous meetings so
overall um you know we believe the
control environment is held up well
um you do have some recommendations
outstanding that will be later on in the
papers so I'll come to that in due
course but for the moment I'll just um
pause there in case there's any comments
or questions
okay
um that wasn't what I was expecting
because I think we expected you to go
through all of them and then I move the
recommendation and then we have
questions at the end so I'm very happy
thank you we'll do them all we'll do
them all in one Big Lot get back to you
okay so um I'll pass on to
um Aaron for the next paper
thank you Greg
um so I'm going to take you through
briefly the progress report which starts
on page 41 of the pack so um there is a
slight duplication with the previous
report because this covers the remaining
audits of 2223 and also our progress
that we've made starting the 23 24
internal audit plan in summary for 22.23
there's three final reports that are
later on in our pack which have all
received either substantial Assurance
opinions for both the design and
operational effectiveness of the
controls the final review we have for
2223 is the Cyber report that is
currently in draft phase
um it's being cleared with management as
you can imagine there's a high risk area
we are receiving additional information
Etc to get to the right conclusion but
that should be completed um I'm told
within the next few weeks and we'll come
to the next committee and we'll take
that into account in our annual opinion
for 23.24 for 23 24 good progress is
being made by the team and good
engagement with the council and officers
to deliver the plan you'll see that
we've got one final report that we're
bringing later on in our pack relating
to the hmrc employment status review
there are free reviews that are now with
field work being the licensing sickness
and absence management and the section
106 review is kicked off as well we've
also got the EDI report
um the that's the equality diversity
inclusion report that's now been in
draft has been issued to management this
week and again we expect that to become
wrapped up and completed and reported to
the next committee and then finally the
only other review there we've got in
progress is the fraud review which are
counter fraud and forensics team are
taking forward and scoping at the moment
and there we will profile the remainder
of the work across the remaining
quarters um that was all I was going to
say about that report
thank you
so it's back to me HC
um so this is the follow-up of previous
recommendations
um so I would say a sort of mixed
picture
um you know I'm pleased to say we have
been able to sign off seven of the uh
outstanding recommendations and that
includes one of the uh flood management
recommendations sorry two of the flood
management recommendations that have
been overdue for some time so that's
good news but there are still a number
outstanding in particular a number of
relating to safeguarding which I know
you know has been a matter of concern
for the committee I will say if you look
at the detail the council are taking
action things are progressing so
particularly in terms of volunteers you
know the database is being set up and
volunteers being contacted so work is is
ongoing which you know obviously is
encouraging but we're not at a position
yet where we can sign those off and we
also had some recommendations where we
didn't receive responses from management
so that's a bit disappointing
um I would say overall probably we need
to continue to work with management to
make sure timetables are realistic when
we produce reports because you know once
once a timetable's been agreed we would
normally expect that to be met so we
need to ensure that that happens going
forwards that would be my my main
comment on that
and if you're happy for me to proceed
um I will go on to 8D which is the
budget and Performance Management report
on page 65.
um so this was given moderate Assurance
for the design and effectiveness of the
controls on the whole I think um good
Arrangements in place a lot of focus
around budget management regular reviews
and this committee is also involved in
terms of the budget position so I think
a lot of good practice there
um the main finding we had was really
about making sure that budgets and
service plans are properly aligned so
obviously it's important that when
you've got your service plan that that
is Affordable it links in with the
budget
um and vice versa that your budgets do
reflect the service priorities so again
work is ongoing to make sure that that
happens going going forwards but that
was our main finding on that one
and if I then move on to 8 e which is
Page 77 that's the main Financial
systems report this got substantial
Assurance for design moderate Assurance
for Effectiveness uh again which means
strong arrangements are in place this
was focusing on accounts receivable so
money owed to the council uh and we we
were able to to verify that invoicing is
happening accurately and on a timely
basis uh the amounts are written off
when they need to be the only issue
there was really around making sure
debts are chased on a timely basis and
all the the reminders that you're
supposed to send out are sent out on
time so that was a control
recommendation having said that if you
actually look at the numbers the council
has brought down its age debt by quite a
large amount it's about half of what it
used to be so clearly something is
working there but you know it could
always get better and you know part of
the purpose of these reports is to
identify best practice going forwards
that then leads me on to 8f which is the
local development plan on page 89 a very
positive uh report here substantial
Assurance on design and Effectiveness uh
very good processes and structures we
felt there's been a lot of effort to
involve members more involve um you know
counselors in the process and make sure
this engagement there so that's all good
the only observation we had is obviously
you did pause your ldp for a period
because of the elections and a number of
councils have paused it because of both
elections and changes in government
policy but obviously you know now that
that's been settled we'd expect that to
proceed um quickly but but in terms of
your process we thought it was very good
and then I'll pass back to Aaron for the
last report thank you I'm taking the
final report which is 8G page 99 onwards
in relation to hmrc employment status
review
um this was an additional review
requested by management following
correspondence with hmrc the report is
advisory in nature so it doesn't have an
opinion attributed to it because of the
specific nature of the work however it
was a really useful exercise it's
outlined the positive culture around how
the council manage off payroll
Arrangements the key finding though is
that there was a slight
misinterpretation of that and over
declare Declaration of the number of
workers who were applicable under that
um instead of there being 10 it should
have only been one
um what we did as well is we talked to
our BDO tax advisory team to confirm
that those errors may do not have any
implications on the council it's about
having the correct numbers so therefore
communicating with hmrc and notifying
them
um will be the the correct fix there and
also what we confirmed was is the right
tax being paid by the right individuals
where that is the council or the
individuals being employed by the
relevant agency and the only other
finding there was a minor one around
ensuring that the training which has
only recently been rolled out um is is
attended by it all and that was all I
was going to say about that report
brilliant thank you everybody very much
for your contributions so the
recommendation is that the committee
considers comments and approves the
following annual report an annual
statement of assurance progress report
July 2023 follow-up of recommendations
report budget and Performance Management
final report May 2053 Main Financial
systems final report June 2023 local
development plan final report July 2023
and the hmrc employment status final
report July June 2023 so I so moved do I
have a second hour thank you cancer
Thompson members I'm sure we have some
comments questions
indeed Council Burwood
um
me too
sorry microphone
um I am really concerned though and this
is probably not a correct question
directly but probably more Mr Johnson Mr
Holmes that you said you didn't receive
some updates with the follow-ups and I'm
assuming we're spending good money on
your reports and if they're not being
followed up by officers that really
concerns me
um and if we could have some kind of
explanation as to why they weren't
followed up I wouldn't be really
grateful thank you thank you I'm going
to turn to uh
directors
and put you on the store now at chairman
I think we've never seen to see the
detail very happy to look at those
individual um uh occurrences and we can
give an explanation back to the
committee thank you very much Mr Holmes
thank you any further questions Council
again
um Council back and before you start
um can you possibly use the other that
is the other one that is the other
microphone
sound is better on that please
we'll go we'll go at my phone I think
we're clear on that one okay I've got a
couple of points um but the first one is
um
what Mr Holmes said there's there's a
lot in there
um and to say we'll go back and have a
look at that I think he's really a a
broad sweeping response to councilor
burwood's question I think we probably
need to look at the detail of it of why
um managers are not getting back to
Auditors when they're requested and no
no you can't respond to that because
there's so many issues within there but
it links in did you did you want to come
back okay I'm just my intent was to do
that find exactly what the issues were
look at them and share that with you so
it won't be glossed over it what we
looked at each instance we've looked at
I'll get an explanation and then we can
we can refer it back to yourselves I
have every confidence thank you very
much the other point is um in a a I'm
glad you explained the that um moderate
because when I saw moderate Assurance I
was a little bit scared to be fair and
he said reasonable and I was much
happier with that language in so
um page 32 it talks about the local
development plan budget you know do we
know what that budget is what's been
spent what's remaining we know I know
the the total sum but do we know where
that was
um and do we also know that with our
options
um that are coming that was discussed at
a fantastic day here a couple of weeks
ago what those sort of costs would be to
cost those options
um and thirdly just in just for the
auditor's response it was not just
members that paused the ldp you know we
we all had different issues to to pause
at ldp and I'm I for one am incredibly
grateful that we're steaming on with a
great team to get that actually resolved
um so there's that point
um because we took a morning when I've
got three points I won't be very long
um page 59
um we talked about the management of
property and there's some targets there
and it was mentioned about Asset
Management earlier on it's something
that was of a degree of concern but
we've got actions in there from August
the 30th 2022 to the 1st of October
which are aspirational targets so 14
months there were people in posts I know
that
um so we really want to look at how long
and how accountable some people are with
regard to closing out those actions
because as the Auditors quite rightly
said I feel that if there is an action
it needs to be addressed or there needs
to be a part action plan to say what
what's been achieved what hasn't been
achieved and what those concerns
actually are
um
they are page 1661 management property
again I think asset has always worried
me the commercial strategy is always
worried me but when you see
um evidence that things are being pushed
out and some of the deterioration of
assets
um I know we're looking at the the key
and the central area master plan and the
prom management plan which is great but
some of the assets down there are
deteriorating so we've really got to I
think up our game a little bit on that
um about you know it talks of repairs
that need doing but we're not doing the
repairs because we're not spending the
time identifying the assets they are so
realistic that I'm I'm personally
concerned from reading the report which
is an excellent report from top to
bottom but I am concerned about the
amount of time some of these actions are
being the the the the the sort of the
Milestones go okay bang we move it from
August to may not done Bank moving from
May till October will we see that again
it's an unanswerable question but it's a
genuine concern that I would have if I
was sitting in a senior management
position
so thank you
so you want to come back
yeah thank you Justin sorry that's right
just with regards to the local
development plan budget that was
um reported to councils both at the
strategy and resources committee meeting
and then that wouldn't that report
around the um budgets and and carry
forward's requests was subsequently
referred to council so
um yeah I I can pull off the exact
numbers but yeah we did have um we did
have a discussion there at those
meetings didn't we around the um the
size of the budget and the fact that
obviously there has been some delay in
spending some of those monies but that
the um the budget holder for that ldp
plan has got a full
um plan of commitments against those
monies and he believes that all of the
work that needs to be done currently can
be contained within that available
budget so members have had sort of sight
of of the budget associated with with
that work
um I'd probably hand over and send to
the asset one to
um
Richards come back so you need to turn
your microphone off Foreign
that's great would you be kind enough
just to recirculate that particular
information because it's very pertinent
at the moment and just that part of
snippet not now obviously because this
is not the Forum thank you
thank you um yes members obviously with
regard to the assets and making progress
of that we're conscious that these items
that work need to be dealt with
um it is a very small team and they have
a lot of priorities
um only today we were looking at the
work priorities of the team we've got
someone also on long-term sickness as
well so we're looking about how we can
bring some of those things forward and
they are now being flagged as risk
through our service plans as well so
conscious that we need to make progress
um it may well be that we'll have to
look at resources around that either
diversing resources are actually asking
for additional resource to make some
progress
um yeah setting down a strategy is
something that we could do with some
external support
um and that would make faster progress
in trying to deal with it internally
ourselves so I think we're looking at
those options now but we're very aware
of the delays that are sitting in that
in that list really
making stones
um yes can't slow run
expensively it still doesn't feel right
yeah it's really expensive there's two
of us yeah so a couple of points
um one I think page 55 or 59 I can't
remember flood risk management training
I know
um some of us do go on about floods but
um I was pleased to see that the aptly
are named flood work stream is is
underway and uh it'll be really good to
see a concrete schedule of flood risk
management training and then the other
point
um I I know safeguarding has been a
concern for some time but hey I'm new so
I can say some of the same things
because it is such an important issue
um likelihood maybe small but obviously
the impact is massive massive and the
history the very long history of some of
those issues concerns me perhaps about
the culture behind it and we still have
an outstanding volunteers so in the
world of Education if an inspector said
you've got some names missing from this
policy or you've got some names missing
from this list if they were kind-hearted
they might say put it on my desk my
clothes of play tomorrow and you'll be
all right but here we're talking about
years
um so so I'm concerned about that and I
do hope that this is going to be
completely rounded off very quickly
thank you thank you I don't know if any
officers would like to decide perhaps on
the flooding first if that's okay so
I've got Mrs Wheatley on the uh call um
Mrs Whitley might give you a bit of an
update around flooding just in general
reassurance on that please
yes hopefully you can hear me okay yes
um so the operational group is meeting
mid-august and we'll be reviewing the
action plan which has been sent to All
group one members in updates of in
advance of the meeting
the group consists of Partners including
Estes County Council I'm Liam Water the
enrollment agency and NDC offices and
this Ops group reports to the modern
flooded and Coastal group who are
meeting in September so they will be
receiving an update then
there are some areas of concern we've
got linebrook where we've requested a
position statement from the environment
agency in relation to this water course
and also Holloway Road where we've
requested detail from the environment
agency regarding any modeling of the
Watercourse as well as parity on the
position regarding the deposit of green
waste on the bank side
um also we're at the North haybridge
Flood alleviation scheme a business case
is currently being prepared by Graham
Robson at the environment agency to
access additional funding external
contributions will be required by
Partners should the scheme go into
delivery and we as Authority have
committed funding towards that apart
from the north Cambridge scheme there
are no other current flood schemes
proposed for Malden although more
Upstate Position will be reported at the
August and September meetings referred
to
thank you thank you very much Miss
Wheatley
okay
thank you chairman and regarding
safeguarding Mr Gill is here this
evening and he will give you an update
thank you
okay just to try and give reassurance
around the contractors and volunteers
list I can confirm the contractors and
volunteers we created a document that
covers both contracts and volunteers
that's been completed uh and there was
some excellent support that I received
and advice from the procurement officer
we've now got this
list and I've worked with departmental
officers to populate that list so that
bits done and now I'm working through
that list contacting contractors
volunteers just to check the
safeguarding compliance update the the
spreadsheet
um and and for me this work now will
become businesses as usual and that list
has been today though but that list has
been updated
um and uploaded to the performance
website so that should be on there
thank you
chairman
thank you German if I could also just
add just again for more reassurance
we're working with the modern CVS around
volunteer
um policy as well so we're linking with
those and obviously they're very um
skilled and expert in that so we're
doing overall sort of policy around that
and that would include um all
volunteering and the way it works uh for
us and also safeguarding is an integral
part of that so I think that's really
helpful and across departments as well
um our other offices obviously um deal
with the public and so we're making sure
it's rolled out right across the council
as well
thank you very much Mr Holmes councilor
Burwood
microphones time
um just regard flood risk and and the
costs
um
I'm really concerned about flooding
obviously I'm a high bridge uh counselor
and the fact that I have residents in my
ward who are paying for flood risk and
flood Management on a monthly basis from
the developers from of their estate and
what I don't want to see is any new
developments anywhere across Malden the
whole of the district where local
residents are having to pay extra for
for flood alleviation because that's
wrong
okay absolutely absolutely I'm slightly
flabbergasted uh there councilor Burwood
I don't know if we can anyone can
respond on that or not really I guess
not really but no absolutely agree with
you cancer Burwood the the residents in
in question are paying in excess of 500
pounds a year towards and it goes up
every year
any other questions
no can we um agree by scent then members
to note those reports Council again
sorry I just want it noted that I don't
Ascend to recommendation to little three
which is a follow-up of recommendations
I think there's too much red and too
much drifting on that so I'd like those
no comments to be noted please if we
could note those everything else is
great thank
gender item
22-23 which can be found on pages 111 to
126 and I'm going to hand over to Mr
Dodson please to present this report
thank you chair
the annual governance statement
structure follows our 2021 template
which was updated at that point to
reflect the Sip for best practice advice
and it's provided as an appendix to the
report
it's provided as a separate item to the
statement of accounts to highlight the
importance of governance in our analysis
of our governance Arrangements over the
2023-22-23 financial year
the report comments on Modern District
council's position against the seven
principles of good governance as
identified by sip for and solace in
2016.
on the first page of the appendix at
page 113 of your report packs we also
highlight the achievements of the
2022-23 financial year in terms of our
governance Arrangements
overall we perform well against the
criteria for good governance
which is also highlighted within the
internal audit statement from BDO on
page 114 of your pack
there are some comments in the report on
areas of Challenge and we've also
identified
an action plan to build on this and
address those those challenges in the to
come in financial year as set out on
page 115 and 116 of the report pack
the covering report provided recommends
that performance governance and audit
committee approve the draft annual
governance statement and that this is
appended to the statement of accounts
and that the committee agree to monitor
the actions are set out thank you chair
thank you very much Mr Dodson so um as
Mr Johnson said the recommendation is to
approve the annual government statement
in appendix a and that this is appended
to the statement of accounts and the
performance governance and audit
committee monitor the progress of the
action plan and as a quarterly report of
annual governance actions is provided
for performance governance and audit
committee review I so moved to have a
second thank you that's a Thompson
um members any comments yes cancer
Spencer
thank you chair
um a couple of comments one is that the
the action plan on one one five one one
six isn't really populated beyond the
broad objectives on the left-hand side
so
in my mind it's very much a work in
progress there's no smart targets there
so I hope we will see those developed
promptly the other thing is Page 119
um in another committee we had
um an update of several policies to do
with fraud bribery Etc and I mentioned
at the time uh whistleblowing policy and
when was it last reviewed and
um people weren't sure in that meeting
but it looks here as if the whistleblown
policy was last reviewed January 2018 so
it's five years old which seems quite a
long time because I've had a lot of
policies in a lot of bodies will go
through a three-yearly review cycle and
with that cycle there is a refreshing uh
for staff of the importance and
significance of those policies and
whistleblowing is extremely relevant to
transparency and the reputation of the
council it's a vital kind of buttress uh
in in keeping us safe in the public eye
uh so so I'd like to ask um when that's
up for review and will staff be
refreshed in that policy
pertinent questions cancer Spencer thank
you Mr Dodson can you
foreign
I don't have the the exact date of the
the review but certainly if not on a
three-year cycle it should definitely be
on a five-year cycle which would mean it
should be reviewed this year which I'll
go away and look at following on from
this meeting thank you good thank you
very much Mr Dudson no I again I Echo
cancer especially the importance of uh
having been a whistleblower in my time
the importance of getting that right
any more questions Council Logan I'm
sure you have some ah this is a surprise
your chair it's actually just to point
out a slight typo and it's on page 119
and it's just underneath the Malden
District Council committee structure and
it says no investigations contact
complaints with District Parish councils
are considered in the committee in the
financial Year 22. yes
2223. slightly uh yeah it's worth the
cause some kind of breach and space-time
Continuum space 1999 comes to mind isn't
it
yeah yeah so I freaking imagine
in the report please thank you for
pointing that out counselor Lagan
extremely diligent any other questions
so points management tonight
no fantastic well thank you very much
um
for that record
so um
yeah can we agree that but I said
members
marvelous thank you very much
moving forward then on to item 10 which
is the infrastructure funding statement
and the section 106 6 monthly update
something that I'm sure we'll look
forward to
um and that's on pages one two seven and
one four two and I was going to defer to
Mr Dodson but I seem as
hello
yes hello and um please can I hand over
to you to um to present this thank you
statement is the yearly statement that
we have to publish on our website
um by December of each year we try and
publish it now as soon as the end of the
financial year has passed so as quickly
as we can bit a bit of a delay this year
because of the elections
um so what it does is it sets out the
position of last year's section 106
agreements basically how much money
we've had in how much money's gone out
and in general how much money we have so
last year was was quite good actually
uh funds coming into the council was
about 1.1 million uh funds going out was
460 k
um so we have money in for affordable
housing uh 64 000 we had 621 000 in for
years to facilities because that was
maybe from
strategic site to a Taylor Rigby sorry
850 pounds train and 423 000 for health
um that's uh once again that's retailer
wimpy so that's Health Services in
Malden and haybridge
um
so now we have we have a really nice pot
for youth facilities and part of the
work now for the council is to set up a
project group to deliver that deliver
that funding spent that's nearly all of
the money now in four years facilities
over 34
000. great
a lot of things
we spent uh 416
000 approximately some of it's going on
affordable housing the pre-planning for
the planning application that's going in
on the land in haybridge
um but some of it's gone on um
valuations for buying a property for
affordable housing
youth facilities we add open space we
passed 87 000 and 19 000 onto
Countryside for on-site delivery at site
2D and that's part appalled
contributions agreement and we spent
fifteen thousand
spend it health spent fifteen thousand
for an options appraisal to look at
their facilities in Burnham
good stuff thank you which is site 2D
Today's Country Countryside so countries
that's your favorite the north haybridge
one thank you thank you very much and
thank you for that
um so the recommendation is that the
committee considers the update on
section 106 planning obligations and
that the committee approves the Malden
District Council infrastructure funding
statement for the financial year 2223
for publication as set out in appendix
one I so moved around a second of thank
you cancer something members comments
please
go on then cancel that and go on go on
go on
um first of all thank you very very much
indeed and for a really good report I
think we've asked for this in simplistic
terms
um with detail that we can understand
from a non-financial basis and speaking
from myself here
um and it's really interesting to be
able to get that data so we can go out
and we can explain to people that money
is coming in and money is going out and
being spent on those things so I just
really wanted to say thank you very much
for an excellent piece of work thank you
super thank you yeah I'd like to Echo
that as I've counselor Thompson thank
you very much for that and just to add
that the important thing is that it gets
spent
that's really important it's no good
just sitting there you know in a pot we
have to make sure that we spend it now
we've got it all in so thank you very
very much and for for that that's really
helpful thank you
um
oh hello no councilwagon's not done yet
I was speaking thank you very
um very it was very synoptic in this
statement um with the manager come in
and we're putting project teams together
I sincerely hope we don't spend a
fortune on Consultants
often if you can use the telepole member
input whatever we can to make sure that
the pennies are spent in the right
places without going outside we're
obviously going to need some expertise
because we we need it but I really think
we've got some expertise inside as well
and I'm sure Mr Holmes and Mr Dodson and
and we will consider that greatly thank
you
thank you I'm sure you will miss times
thank you any further points or
questions
thank you member so um can we agree that
by centuries
yep super thank you very much
so this brings us on to item 11 which
was deferred from the last meeting which
is appointment of Representatives to
outside bodies and it's to a point to
the vacancy on the Malden Museum in the
park liaison committee
um minute 98 refers now I know councilor
Shawnee so you took on one of the
positions does do we have any other
committee members that are willing to
take on the um
you're almost sitting line like you did
at school where you've got both your
hands as far down as possible because
nobody wants to
to do this some members in light of that
I will take this role on so if nobody
objects to that thank you
I I will take on the second um roles I
look forward to working with you cancer
sure want to see and and the museum
okay then nothing with this so that
brings us on to
um I'm gonna have to ask Mr actually I'm
gonna ask you cancer something if you
would bang my gavel for me so
um I therefore close this meeting at 8
22. no urgent business no
thank you very much